mes chers collègues nous accueillons à
présent monsieur Éric Dupont Moretti
garde des saau ministre de la Justice
monsieur le ministre je vous souhaite la
bienvenue et vous remercie de votre
disponibilité pour répondre à nos
questions nous avons entamé les travaux
de cette commission d'enquête sur
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le 20 juillet dernier nos
travaux portent sur trois axes les
violences physiques sexuel ou
psychologique dans le sport les
discriminations sexuelles et raciales et
les problématiques liées à la
gouvernance financière des organismes de
gouvernance du monde
sportif lors de la 4e Convention
nationale de prévention des violences
dans le sport vous aviez déclaré je vous
cite si de primabord on peut penser que
la justice et le sport sont deux thèmes
qui n'ont pas grand-chose en commun il
n'en est rien la lutte contre toutes les
violences dans le domaine du sport est
une préoccup
majeure du ministère de la
Justice quelles actions déployez-vous
dans ce domaine comment les spécificités
du monde sportif sont-elles appréhendées
par le ministère de la Justice quelle
appréciation portez-vous sur le cadre et
l'organisation existant pour prévenir
détecter signaler et sanctionner les
violences sexuelles et sexistes les
actes de discrimination et de racisme ou
les atteintes à la probité dans le
milieu
sportif nos travaux ont soulevé de
nombreuses rogation en lien avec le
champ de compétence de votre ministère
en particulier des difficultés
importantes d'articulation entre les
procédures judiciaires administratives
et disciplina disciplinaires des failles
dans le contrôle de l'honorabilité des
condamnation qui serait insuffisamment
accompagné d'une interdiction d'exercer
un défaut de signalement par les
personnes qui sont tenu ou encore une
méconnaissance du cadre et des
obligations déroulant de l'article 40
par ceux qui sont censés les
appliquer je rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendues par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre
micro je le jure madame la Présidente je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre et
vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente Madame
la rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés il y a un peu plus de 3 ans
maintenant la patineuse artistique
française Sarah Bitbol publiaé son livre
intitulé un si long
silence c'est un livre qui a provoqué
une véritable déflagration dans notre
dans notre
société et dans ce livre Sarah beitb
décrivait les viols les agressions
sexuelles que son entraîneur lui avait
fait subir alors qu'elle n'était qu'une
toute jeune femme le courage de cette
sportive nous a permis bien sûr de
d'ouvrir les yeux sur des crimes
étouffés dans dans l'intimité d'un
vestière d'une chambre d'enfant d'une
d'une chambre d'hôtel et le cri de cette
jeune femme et de Cell et de ceux qui
ont suivi a permis de lever le voile au
fond sur le le le secret le mieux garder
des milieux
sportifs le sport est synonyme
d'épanouissement d'équilibre il permet
de lutter contre contre l'exclusion
il est le vecteur précieux de valeur
comme la fraternité le le le respect
d'autrui le dépassement de soi et nous
avons
été les uns et les autres sidérés par
par ces
révélation alors madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur face au caractère
protéiforme des violences qui sont
commises dans le milieu sportif il était
évidemment nécessaire de de réagir et et
et de définir un vaste plan d'action
permettez-moi tout d'abord de de saluer
le le travail de l'ancienne ministre des
Sports Roxana marassin àous qui a
mobilisé autour de trois conventions
nationales en février 2020 en avril 2021
et en mars
2022 tous les ministères concernés
enfance justice éducation nationale
égalité afin de prévenir euh toute tout
les formes de violence dans le sport et
de protéger tous les sportifs l'actuelle
ministre Amélie oua Castera a poursuivi
avec beaucoup de force beaucoup de
détermination et un total engagement
cette action et la 4èe Convention
nationale qui s'est tenu le 3 juillet
dernier a notamment permis de dresser un
état des lieux sans concession des
signalements reçus par la cellule du
ministère des sports ainsi le le
dispositif national signal sport créé en
2020 a permis de
recueillir plus de 1000 signalements
1095 précisément de violence sexuelle ou
ou
sexiste conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
ces signalements lorsqu'il révèle la
commission d'infraction pénale sont
transmis comme il se doit au procureur
de la République mais je suis là
aujourd'hui parmi vous pour vous parler
d'abord et avant tout du périmètre qui
est le mien le ministère de la
Justice je veux pas me payer de mots
mais je veux dire que mon engagement est
celui de tous les acteurs du ministère
sur ce sujet est est total et je
souhaite ici rendre un hommage appuyer à
ceux qui dans les juridictions et dans
les
prisons lutte et réprime les violences
commises contre les femmes et les
enfants car il est surtout question de
cela aujourd'hui et avant d'être le plus
exhaustif et le plus précis possible je
souhaite vous présenter madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les
députés mon plan d'action autour de de
trois axes
essentiels
premièrement les actions concrètes qui
ont été déployées pour sensibiliser les
professionnels si la formation des
magistrats est complète en matière de
lutte contre les infraction
sexuelle il est important en revanche de
renforcer l'articulation entre les
actions judiciaires et les actions
administratives
entre les procédures judiciaires et les
procédures
administrative j'ai souhaité diffuser en
en décembre
des outils
pratiques à destination des
magistrats leur permettant de mettre en
œuvere cette
articulation un focus dédié à la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles dans le
sport rappelle ainsi le cadre légal des
obligations de signalement et
d'information respectiv entre les
services administratifs et les
procureurs de manière extrêmement
pratique un listing des coordonnées des
directions déconcentrées du sport a été
diffusé et il est désormais à la
disposition de tous les procureurs dans
le cadre de leur
permanence les relations entre les
parquets et les services déconcentrés
des sports ont ainsi été renforcé les
procureurs peuvent transmettre de
manière
sécurisée toutes les Formation
Judiciaire aux autorités administratives
lorsquun éducateur sportif ou un
directeur de fédération et mise en cause
pour des faits de violences commises à
l'encontre de mineurs il était
absolument
nécessaire que les échanges
d'informations entre les fédérations et
les
procureurs soient
fluidifié
systématisé dans le cadre bien sûr d'un
secret
partager secret protecteur des mineurs
l'objectif est de s'assurer que les
fédérations Sportiv puissent
réagir pardonnez-moi vite lorsqu'elles
sont informées qu'une enquête judiciaire
est
ouverte afin de faire cesser tout
contact avec des mineurs au-delà des
mesures de sûreté judiciaire et sur ce
point il est certain qu'il est souvent
complexe de concilier le temps de
l'enquête le temps de l'enquête
judiciaire avec des mesures
disciplinaires il n'en demeure pas moins
que les fédérations réagissent mieux en
prononçant des mesures de
suspension les procureurs madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur mesdames
et Messieurs les les
députés ont également été incités à se
rapprocher des services déconcentrés des
sports en associant les comités sportifs
dans le cadre des instances
partenariales existantes pilotées par
les procureurs et les
préfet les violences commises dans le
sport à l'encontre des plus jeunes
sportifs ont
évidemment vocas à
être le plus rapidement possible
appréhender judiciairement selon les
instructions plus récentes issue d'une
circulaire que j'ai signé le 28 mars
dernier circulaire à la lutte contre les
violences faites aux mineurs j'y
rappelle la nécessité de resserrer les
liens entre parquet services
départementaux ou régionaux à la
jeunesse j'y invite à la signature de
convention pour encadrer les
signalements j'y rappelle l'intérêt
d'associer les représentants
départementaux des comités sportifs aux
réunion du comité départemental de
prévention de la délinquence ou du
comité local d'aide
je voudrais illustrer mon propos par
deux exemples à Rennes et à saintmalot
les procureurs ont intégré la
problématique des violences en milieu
sportif dans le schéma directeur
départemental de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes réunissant
tous les acteurs concernés préfet ARS
éducation nationale conseil
départemental
ville
FSI services sociaux soignants
association et cette
partenariale dans la droite lignée des
instructions que j'ai pu diffuser depuis
mon arrivée au ministère et la garantie
d'une lutte efficace contre les
violences perpétré dans le milieu
sportif une fois les fait signalé par
les instances
sportives signaler au procureur de la
République la parole de la victime
mineure doit pouvoir être recueillie de
manière sereine le temps de l'enquête
paril demande au Vic de venir sur les
faits subis pour les raconter les
raconter à nouveau parfois peut-être
source de traumatisme supplémentair on
parle d'ailleurs souvent de de de
parcours du combattant en particulier
bien sûr pour les victimes les plus
vulnérables les enfants qui doivent
pouvoir être accueillis une fois qu'ils
ont eu la force de parler dans des lieux
adaptés unique offrant une prise en
charge complète j'évoque ici madame la
Présidente le déploiement des unités
d'accueil pédiatrique enfance en
danger connu sous l'acronye de
uaped nous encontons 145 sur l'ensemble
du territoire national nous avions un
premier projet qui était de doter chaque
département d'un ueaped nous sommes
allés plus loin et nous souhaitons
désormais que il y ait une telle
structure dans chaque ressort judiciaire
164 ressorts judiciaires euh tribunaux
judiciaaires dans notre pays nous en
avons maintenant 145 et d'ici 2025
chaque tribunal judiciaire bénéficiera
d'une telle
unité les victimes souvent nous savons
on par ailleurs besoin de de temps avant
de saisir la justice et j'ai adressé le
le 26 février 2021 une dépêche au
procureur généraux et au procureur de la
République tendant à l'ouverture
d'enquête euh pénale
systématique lorsque les faits révélés
sont
anciens voire même susceptible au
premier regard d'être pres prescrit ces
enquêtes permettent notamment de
réaliser des investigation dans
l'environnement du mise en cause
d'identifier le cas échéant d'autres
victimes pour lesquelles les faits ne
sont pas prescrit et pour permettre des
poursuites contre l'auteur de ces faits
bien sûr chaque fois que cela est
possible tout petit mot une toute petite
parenthèse sur la mise en place du chien
d'assistance judiciaire qui permettent à
des enfants en basage qui n'ont pas
toujours la force de dire les choses qui
sont prostraits qui sont dans le silence
de débloquer leurs paroles ces chiens
d'assistant judiciairees ont fait leurs
preuve je suis allé voir sur place dans
différentes juridictions et les
enquêteurs et les juges d'instruction
d'ailleurs m'ont dit qu'après avoir
expérimenté la présence de chien
assistant judiciaire il ne voulait
absolument plus s'en passer donc on est
en train de de de développer ça parce
que c'est utile pour que les enfants
puissent dire les choses en se sentant
sécurisé
euh je veux dire aussi je je je vais
ouvrir cette parenthèse et la refermé
mais toujours pour que l'enfant puisse
dire les choses quand obligatoirement
euh
ils doivent venir témoigner c'est
parfois indispensable pas toujours mais
parfois on fait en sorte qu'ils soit
accompagné par une association d'Aid aux
victimes dans les lieux mêmes où le
procès doit se dérouler pour que les
enfants appréhendent le lieu n'en ait
pas peur qu'il puisse circuler partout
voir monter sur les différents fauteuils
qui sont réservés au magistrat lors du
procès voir ce qui est une robe de
magistrat et cetera et cetera on est
allé
expérimenter cela à l'étranger on a
trouvé que c'était une bonne idée on a
souhaité le mettre en place et le
développer deuxè axe madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les députés nous avons mis
en œuvre un certain nombre de mesures
visant à prévenir le renouvellement des
infractions d'abord en informant les
autorités sportives des enquêtes
ouvertes contre leur employés ou
bénévoles la loi prévoit que dès la mise
en examen ou l'engagement des poursuites
la structure employé en inéressé doit
être informé des faits qui lui sont
reprochés dans les conditions prévues
par les articles 706-
47-4 et 11-2 du code de procédure pénale
cette information permet à
l'administration d'engager à l'encontre
du suspect une procédure de suspension
de ces activités à titre conservatoire
par
ailleurs je rappelle que l'autorité
judiciaire peut attravers les mesures de
sûreté mettre un terme aux activités de
la personne suspectée de violence
sexuelle soit elle est placée en
détention provisoire soit elle est
astreinte à un contrôle judiciaire avec
interdiction d'exercer toute activité
impliquante un contact habituel avec les
mineurs et de paraître dans les lieux
accueillant des enfants ou ou aux abords
de ces lieux
enfin les condamnations des dirigeants
ou encadrants sportifs sont
systématiquement transmise au casier
judiciaire national pour favoriser
l'alimentation du figesss ficiier
judiciaire des auteurs d'infraction
sexuelles ou de violence ma circulaire
du mois de mars 2023 sur la lutte contre
les violences faites aux mineurs
rappelle de façon très claire au
procureur que cette transmission dans
les plus brefs délais des condamnations
est indispensable car elle permet de
garantir l'effectivité des contrôles
d'honorabilité réalisés par le ministère
des Sports et à cet égard il faut
prévoir que le contrôle d'honorabilité
des éducateurs des bénévoles au sein des
clubs et fédérations est désormais
automatique le ministère des Sports vous
le savez c'est doté d'un système
informatique de de vérification des
antécédents judiciaires et de
consultation du
figès madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur c'est plus d'un million de
contrôles qui ont été ainsi réalisés par
le ministère des Sports depuis
2021 je veux ici souligner la la grande
réactivité du ministère des Sports qui
est en capacité de fournir des listes
automatisées de tous les éducateurs
sportifs même bénévole avec à terme près
de 2 millions d'identités qui seront
ainsi soumises et comparées aux
identités enregistrées par les
juridictions dans le
figes dès lors que le contrôle
d'honorabilité relève une inscription au
figess et que la condamnation est
définitive l'incapacité professionnelle
ou sociale est alors notifié à
l'intéressé par le préfet la personne ne
peut plus prétendre ou ne peut plus
exercer une profession ou une activité
la plaçant au contact de mineur vous
pouvez constater ainsi que les filières
de l'urgence mises en place dans les
juridictions en lien avec les services
des sports permettent de couvrir toute
la chaîne pénale de la phase
présententielle réception des
signalements plaines procédur jusqu'à la
phase
postsententielle enfin mon dernier axe
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
députés c'est l'amélioration de notre
arsenal
répressif je vais m'arrêter un instant
bien sûr sur la loi du 21 avril 2021
Visante à protéger les mineurs des
crimes et des l sexuels et de l'inceste
initié par la sénatrice Billon et voter
à l'unanimité et c'est un texte
euh je le pense
historique le
principe que pose cette loi trouve
pleinement à s'appliquer dans le monde
du sport aucun adulte ne peut se
prévaloir du consentement d'un mineur de
moins de 15 ans à une relation sexuelle
les choses sont claires encore
fallait-il que nous précisions ces
éléments et ce texte prolonge ainsi la
prescription des FA sexuel répété commis
par un même auteur à l'occasion à
l'encontre de plusieurs mineurs afin que
toutes les infractions commises par
cette par cette personne puissent être
jugé ensemble avec ce nouveau mécanisme
de prescription prolongé au bénéfice des
mineurs agressés par un même auteur la
situation de particulière vulnérabilité
des mineurs victimes qui peuvent parfois
mettre plusieurs années pour révéler et
lesffit a ainsi été pris en compte par
le législateur vous le voyez la
libération de la parole dans le monde du
sport a permis une prise de conscience
au sein de de de notre société qu'il
nous était indispensable de
transformer en action concrètes pour
mieux protéger nos
concitoyens c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire sans désemparer depuis ma prise de
fonction au ministère de la Justice et
les choses bougent car cette prise de s
traduite par des mesures législatives
réglementaires indispensa pour
sanctionner les auteurs de ces crimes
auieux mais également pour prévenir la
commission de telles infractions la
protection des sportifs et notamment des
plus jeunes d'entre eux est un combat
que nous
devons mener à à à bras le corp nous
devons en effet faire en sorte que le
sport reste ce qu'il doit toujours être
un moment de passion de dépassement de
soi
convivialité de partage de valeurs qui
qui nous rendre meilleur je suis Madame
la présidente Madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés à
votre disposition pour répondre à toutes
les questions que vous voudrez bien me
poser merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
la
rapporteur
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
propos liminaire et de votre
disponibilité aujourd'hui pour répondre
à à nos questions peut-être moi je vais
repartir justement de ce que vous nous
avez indiqué parce que on arrive à la
fin des auditions de cette commission
d'enquête aujourd'hui je crois qu'on va
terminer on aura fait 90 auditions au
total dans le cadre de cette
commission on a entendu énormément
d'acteurs forcément de de ce mouvement
sportif avec des interrogation et et
beaucoup en tout cas nous ce qu'on a pu
relever des dysfonctionnements parfois
qui sont internes parfois au propres
fédération dans les relations avec le
ministère de tutelle mais aussi parfois
en lien avec le ministère de la Justice
peut-être moi je je voudrais commencer
par une question sur ce que vous avez
évoqué c'est le fait qu'il y ait une
communication euh euh de la justice
vis-à-vis des fédérations en tout cas du
ministère en ce qui concerne des enqu ou
des affaires qui sont ouvertes ce qui
nous a été remonté nous euh des
présidents de fédération très
régulièrement c'est que au contraire il
n'était pas informé
euh voire parfois quand ils le sont la
justice demande à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
de mesures disciplinaires qui soient
misise en place ni de sanction euh
vis-à-vis des personnes qui
sont qui qui ont été signalé pour ne pas
nuire à l'enquête en cours ce qui pose
plusieurs difficultés pour le club ou
pour la ligue ou même pour la fédération
dans laquelle dans laquelle la la
personne est accueillie puisqu'elle est
toujours en contact de mineurs lorsqu'il
s'agit d'entraîneur par exemple et que
parfois le temps de l'enquête peut-être
très long et on l'a vu dans certaines
affaires il a fallu 2 ans 3 ans pour que
finalement la Fédération décide de
prendre une sanction vis-à-vis de
l'auteur présumé donc comment est-ce
qu'on peut justement peut-être avancer
sur cette question parce que il y a une
autre un autre sujet sous-jacent qui a
été vraiment tout le temps évoqué par
les présidents de fédération c'est la No
de présempption d'innocence et à chaque
fois ils nous disent tant qu'il n'y a
pas de condamnation il est difficile
pour nous de prononcer des sanctions y
compris d'ailleurs des des sanctions à
titre conservatoire parce que souvent
ils ont le risque d'avoir des actions en
justice contre eux et parfois les les
personnes nobtiennent d'ailleurs rain de
cause sur le fait qu'ils ont été mis bah
qu'ils ont été sanctionnés à titre
conservatoire sans qu'il y a une
décision de justice donc j'avoue que
c'est un peu l'angle mort qui a été
identifié par notre commission et
peut-être on souhaiterait vraiment vous
entendre
là-dessus le le problème que que vous
évoquez madame la rapporteur est un
problème que l'on
retrouve un peu partout chaque fois
qu'il y a une possible dualité entre la
discipline et la procédure pénale qui
s'agisse de la discipline des magistrats
qu' s'agisse de la discipline des
avocats de la discipline des policiers
de la discipline en l'occurrence parce
que il y a le respect de la présomption
d'innocence d'une part vous l'avez dit
vous-même et au fond si je puis me
permettre la réponse est déjà dans la
question et votre question est très
complète il y a aussi le risque d'une
interférence parfois entre l'audience
disciplinaire l'instance disciplinaire
et l'instance judiciaire donc c'est très
compliqué et la justice je le dis euh
euh a parfois besoin de temps bien
sûr pour euh recueillir différents
témoignages il y a il y a tout un
travail probatoire naturellement qui
doit être euh mis en œuvre ce qui est
sûr c'est que une fois que dans le le
alors on est dans le post sententiel je
je je je j'avance un peu dans la dans la
chronologie euh chaque fois qu'une
condamnation est prononcée il y a une
obligation euh du parquet d'informer et
chaque fois que une instance
disciplinaire a tranché elle doit
également informer le parquet de la
décision qui est prise euh moi je serai
je je je le dis j'ai une une une vraie
volonté d'avancer sur ces sujets d'être
le plus efficace possible tout ça
évidemment euh et transpartisan mais euh
l'idée que nos enfants puissent aller
dans un club sportif et se retrouver euh
victime d'agissement insupportable euh
ça nous aimut et ça nous oblige euh je
serai aussi très attentif au prè
onisation bien sûr de votre commission
je c'est pas des choses que que que l'on
que l'on rejette d'un revers de manche
ministériel au contraire il faut s'en
emparer et voir comment on peut
améliorer la situation mais j'entends
que ce que vous
évoquez on est dans une forme de zone
grise c'est très très compliqué est-ce
que est-ce que je peux moi demander
demain au parquet
euh de
pas de ne pas communiquer non bien sûr
d'un point de vue post dans la
chronologie je l'ai dit après
condamnation c'est une obligation avant
ça peut poser un certain nombre de
problèmes aussi la la la la justice a
parfois besoin d'investigations qui sont
secrètte le secret de l'instruction ça
n'est pas rien non plus voz et et toutes
ces questions je le dis on les retrouve
dans dans tout le disciplinaire je je
suis moi en permanence
confronté à des difficultés de cette
teinture je je je je veux vous indiquer
que parfois d'ailleurs le disciplinaire
souhaite attendre le résultat du
pénal parfois non d'ailleurs parfois on
est à la fois dans du disciplinaire et
et ce qui n'empêche pas la procédure
pénale de prospérer mais à la condition
bien sûr que au fond le disciplinaire ne
vienne pas entraver l'action judiciaire
donc je je j'ai pas de réponse précise à
vous donner sur cette question je le
redis c'est une véritable difficulté
pour nous euh d'être dans une réponse
euh comment dirais-je binaire parce que
tout est une question de de nuance et de
et de cas d'espèce d'une certaine façon
alors la circulaire elle est très claire
pour pour en terminer avec des
obligations pour les procureurs de
transmettre à chaque étape de la
procédure les informations aux instances
disciplinaires dans le respect de la
présomption innocence euh et notamment
euh le juge d'instruction ordonne par
exemple dans le cadre d'un contrôle
judiciaire l'interdiction d'être au
contact des enfants ben là pour le coup
il est tout à fait normal que l'autorité
judiciaire viennent dire aux autorités
sportives nous avons pris un certain
nombre de mesures monsieur Intel ne peut
plus être au contact des enfants mais il
y a des situations dans lesquelles et et
légitimement d'ailleurs l'autorité
judiciaire ne peut pas communiquer tout
tout est une question
de de cas d'espèce si vous me permettez
mais en revanche je je veux insister sur
le fait que les procureurs généraux les
procureurs sont sensibilisés maintenant
évidemment à cette question et que ils
doivent agir en interférence avec les
différents clubs les différentes
fédérations vous
savez moi je suis je suis très heureux
de de d'exprimer ça parce que je pense
que la solution à un certain nombre de
nos mots c'est que les uns et les autres
ne fonctionnent plus en silo euh dans
les violences intrafamiliales c'est
exactement la même chose il faut que les
différents magistrats quel que soi leurs
compétences et leurs périmètres puissent
communiquer entre eux ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas et ce qui a généré
des drames comme celui de mérigac mrigac
il y a pas de faute individuelle dira
l'inspection général de la justice mais
il y a en revanche un défaut de
communication entre les uns et les
autres et il faut que tout le monde se
parle que tout le monde se mette autour
de la table et peut-être même change un
certain nombre d'habitudes le le le
préfet je l'ai dit tout à l'heure la la
RS les différents clubs le procureur de
la République dans le cadre de
l'exécution des peines et cetera c'est
ça qui permet de mieux appréhender la
délinquence et de
mieux et d'être plus efficace pardon
pour cette réponse un peu longue qui
n'atteint pas le niveau de précision
vous auriez peut-être espéré mais toute
la difficulté réside dans la dualité
entre disciplinaire et et
judiciaire oh pardon
merci alors j'entends tout à fait la
question de la transmission sauf que
c'est vrai que nous dans le cadre des
différentes auditions on a pu constater
malheureusement que plusieurs présidents
de club ont appris
les affaires qui concernaient leur club
dans la
presse sans en avoir été informé en
amont donc ils ont pas pu ni prendre de
mesures disciplinaires ni faire remonter
lesffet donc peut-être voilà revenir sur
la la procédure exacte voilà quand il y
a quand il y a une affaire qui se
déclenche quand il y a une plainte qui
est déposée parce qu' on le sait
aujourd'hui on en a beaucoup parlé
notamment la plateforme signal sport
donc on sait que pour signaler on a le
signal sport on a la plante quand ça
passe par la plante ça ça ça remonte où
est-ce que ça va au ministère des Sports
puis aux fédérations est-ce que ça va
directement aux fédérations au club et
juste peut-être une petite question
là-dessus est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
prévoir dans la loi que les fédérations
sportives aent l'obligation de suspendre
à titre conservatoire la licence d'une
personne sur laquelle pèse des des
indices graves et concordants je vous
pose cette question parce que d'abord on
a eu plusieurs présidents de fédération
ici qui n'étaient pas au courant qui
pouvait suspendre donc qui ne
connaissait pas les mesures
disciplinaires dont il disposaient et
euh très souvent ils se sont pas cachés
mais ils ont utilisé l'argument de la
présomption d'innocence pour dire ah non
nous on ne prend pas la mesure à titre
conservatoire parce que derrière on aura
une plainte donc si on l'inscrivait dans
la loi est-ce que ça ne clarifierait pas
les choses pour ces présidents de
fédération euh deux choses voyez quand
je quand je dis tout à l'heure il peut
pas y avoir de réponses binaire et et on
est sur du cas par cas je souscris
totalement à à vos propos il n'est quand
même pas normal qu'un club apprenne en
lisant la presse que qu'un de ses
moniteurs éducateurs et cetera fait
l'objet d'une procédure B là on est sur
quelque chose qui est assez singulier à
vrai dire ma circulaire elle est très
claire je sais pas si vous l'avez je
vous la transmettre il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui sont dites de façon
un peu un peu
cominatoire pour justement créer
davantage de lien entre entre les clubs
et l'autorité judiciaire l'exemple que
vous donner l'exemple type de choses qui
qui évidemment formuler comme vous le
formulez je je ne reviens pas sur la
formulation elle est tout à fait exacte
nous laisse quand même pant toi c'est
vrai que c'est pas en ouvrant la Gazette
que le club peut se dire j'ai
potentiellement parmi mes éducateurs
quelqu'un qui
bon la suspension à titre conservatoire
disciplinaire c'est déjà une mesure qui
existe à titre disciplinaire est-ce
qu'il faut la rendre obligatoire
il est évident je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure que si un juge d'instruction
décide dans le cadre d'un contrôle
judiciaire
d'interdire un mise en examen d'exercer
son activité professionnelle ou de
contacter des enfants de s'approcher
d'un lieu où il y a des gamins
ou aux abords de bah il est évident que
là on a quelque chose qui est
obligatoire puisque vous savez que le
contrôle judiciaire s'il n'est pas
respecté peut-être sanctionné bon par la
révocation du dit contrôle judiciaire et
par des mesures coeritives qui sont bien
plus
fortes madame la rapporteur vous me
prenez un peu de cours sur le caractère
automatique de la suspension
conservatoire on peut y réfléchir
et pourquoi pas la systématisation pour
ne rien vous cacher moi ça me dérange
toujours un
peu parce que on enlève de la liberté
alors s'agissant des magistrats on a pu
appeler ça la peine pl planché par
exemple on a eu de longs débats
là-dessus qui est pas très
constitutionnel même pas du tout à vrai
dire si c'est une vraie peine planchée
pour une raison toute simple c'est que
vous enlevez à l'autorité judiciaire un
certain nombre de ces prérogatives et
qu'au fond on impose au juges et je
rappelle que dans notre pays la justice
est indépendante sur le terrain
disciplinaire il faut voir comment les
choses s'articulent
moi je suis sous serment devant vous ces
sujets évidemment me me me préoccupent
infiniment on se retrouve tous dans dans
ces affaires on se dit tous qu'on aurait
pu avoir un gamin malheureusement
victime ou et cetera
bon vos préconisations je vais les lire
avec beaucoup d'attention vous dire là
maintenant il faut suspendre à titre
conservatoire de façon
systématique ça
mérite une analyse et peut-être une
analyse de la daacg par exemple pour
nous dire comment on peut avancer sur
ces questions
bon
pardon je dois également vous dire que
le le le le ministre vous le
savez le ministre vous le savez ne peut
pas donner de de directive individuelle
au procureur bon non mais pourquoi je
vous rappelle ça tout le monde a ça à
l'esprit bien sûr il peut pas non plus
demander au procureur de communiquer
bon c'est une initiative qui appartient
au au procureur il a la possibilité de
communiquer et en
réalité il le
fait au trébucher de l'importance que
pourrait avoir cette communication dans
le déroulement de la procédure qu'il a
ouverte et il s'agit pas qu'une
communication puisse potentiellement
contaminer l'efficacité du une
intervention judiciaire donc là je pense
qu'il faut laisser beaucoup d'élasticité
même si Madame disons les choses très
très
clairement il y a forcément un certain
nombre de défauts de communication qui
ont été portés à votre
connaissance mais il y a aussi des
choses qui fonctionne parfaitement bien
et et et et et moi je j'affirme que les
les les parquets ont pleinement
conscience il sont comme nous les
procureurs les violences qui sont
commises dans le sport c'est quelque
chose qui qui qui évidemment suscite
leur réprobation et et et et les les
motivent évidemment à agir enfin c'est
une évidence c'est c'est une évidence
que de le dire donc attention à ce que
la
systématisation ne vienne pas entraver
l'action voilà ce que je je peux vous
répondre de façon un peu générale j'ai
conscience que c'est une réponse un peu
générale mais je vois pas comment je
peux la formuler
autrement
merci peut-être une question sur le
contrôle d'honorabilité puisque vous
l'avez évoqué dans votre propos
introductif nos travaux comme le le
dernier reportage qui a été diffusé par
M6 notamment sur les violences sexuel
dans le football révèle des failles
importantes dans ce contrôle
d'honorabilité est-ce que vous avez été
alerté de ces failles est-ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des mesures qui sont
envisagées justement pour pour y
remédier
alors là-dessus quand on est dans le
domaine du postsententiel les choses
elles sont extrêmement claires il y a
nécessité
d'informer je n'ai pas été
personnellement averti d'un certain
nombre de failles disons les choses
clairement quelqu'un qui aurait été
condamné et le club par exemple ou les
instances sportives n'auraient pas été
informé mais bon c'est à l'évidence un
dysfonctionnement je peux pas utiliser
un autre mot je peux pas être plus clair
c'est évidemment un
dysfonctionnement peut-être pour être un
peu plus précise il y a
plusieurs plusieurs alertes qui nous en
tout cas nous nous ont été faites la
première c'est lorsque
les lorsqu'on remplit le fichier donc
des des personnes qui doivent êre
contrôleré notamment nous on a pu le
constater à la Fédération d'athlétisme
il y a des centaines de retours de mail
sur le le croisement du fichier donc qui
ne fonctionne pas parce que parfois une
virgule un mot près enfin à une lettre
près en fait ils ont vraiment moi je
l'ai vu à la Fédération d'athlétisme ils
avaient plus de 500 mails qui étaient
revenus en retour sur lequel il ne
pouvaient pas faire les contrôles
d'honorabilité parce qu'au moment du
croisement du fichier en fait les
données revenaient à la fédération en
leur indiquant que il y avait soit un
une lettre qui changeait soit un chiffre
soit et cetera et donc ça demande
énormément de travail pour les bénévoles
des des clubs et des fédérations en tout
cas ça c'est un premier un premier
élément qui nous a été remonté le
deuxième c'est que sur le périmètre en
tant que tel du contrôle
d'honorabilité on le voit d'ailleurs
dans le documentaire
d'M6 ce fameux entraîneur qui a pu sévir
pendant plusieurs années il y avait bien
eu un contrôle d'honorabilité qui avait
été fait il y avait bien eu un signal
qui avait été fait donc un courrier
envoyé à la Fédération et au club sur le
fait que cette personne ne pouvait plus
encadrer mais comme il n'était pas
considéré comme administrateur je crois
que c'était ça la subtilité la
Fédération a quand même réaccordé une
licence ce qui lui a permis de reprendre
une activité auprès d'un public mineur
et c'était il avait déjà été condamné
deux fois par la justice sur des
agression sexuelle sur mineurs donc
voilà ça c'est le type de
dysfonctionnement qui nous a été en tout
cas qui nous a qui a été porté à la
connaissance de cette
commission alors bon ce contrôle
d'honorabilité des éducateurs sportifs
il est effectif depuis 2013 bon il a
beaucoup
évolué il s'opère de deux façons
consultation du bulletin numéro 2 du
casier judiciaire et consultation du
figess sur l'année écoulée il y a 70000
bulletin 2 qui ont été demandés et 82000
consultations du
figes au cours de l'année 2020 il y a
des travaux juridique et technique qui
ont été conduits par mon ministère et
par celui des sports afin de mettre en
place un contrôle de l'honorabilité des
éducateurs
sportifs bénévooles et ce contrôle est
devenu effectif en juin 2021 avec la
mise en place là encore la consultation
du dossier figes
sur l'année écoulée c'est
720000 consultations du figes qui ont
été effectuées au titre des bénévoles je
vous ai donné le chiffre tout à l'heure
pour
les pour les éducateurs sportifs
professionnels
euh les circuits vous les évoquez dans
leur mise en œuvre relèv du périmètre du
ministère des
Sports
euh j'ajoute que dans les modifications
qui sont intervenues les casiers
judiciaires
étrangers peuvent être consultés vous
avez des clubs évidemment qui sont
frontaliers et qui peuvent
accueillir des bénévoles ou des
professionnels étrangers la directive UE
de décembre 2011 prévoit expressément
l'utilisation du système européen
d'information des casiers
judiciaire et en outre sont inscrites au
f Gest et condamnations prononcées par
les juridictions étrangères en vertu de
conventions qui ont été conclues entre
la France et d'autres pays
euh voilà ce que ce que ce ce que je
peux vous dire
euh évidemment on est tout à fait
preneur sachant et je le redis que la
mise en œuvre des circuits relève du
ministère des sports mais si on peut
apporter comment dirais-je une
amélioration technique ou juridique pour
que les choses se fassent encore mieux
notons tout de même que a peut-être
dératé vous le dites bien sûr mais il y
a une considérable évolution par rapport
aux années aux années aux années
antérieures sur ces questions
puisqueévidemment la vigilance qui nous
qui nous
oblige nous fait traduire un certain
nombre de de d'actions dans dans
pragmatique pour qu'évidemment les clubs
soient soient informés alors on
a des projets qui visent à étendre les
consultations administratives du figes
et en 2024 il y a une modification des
textes réglementaires qui doit
intervenir pour permettre au ministère
de l'Agriculture et de la culture
d'accéder au figè et mise en place
prochaine sous l'égide de la direction
générale de la cohésion sociale de
consultation automatisé dans le secteur
de la petite
enfance j'évoque ici les assistants
maternels et familiaux personnels des
structures qui accueillent des mineurs
relevant du code de l'action sociale et
de la famille pour améliorer évidemment
les vérifications dans ces secteurs qui
sont par définition des secteurs
potentiellement sensibles ou
sensible une question notre collègue
Stéphane
Mazar merci madame la présidente
monsieur le
ministre je
reviens
sur sur les échanges que vous venez
d'avoir avec Madame la rapporteur
sur sur le début de ces procédures parce
que c'est vrai que au terme de ces 90
auditions réalisées par la commission
d'enquête on a beaucoup tourné autour de
ces
notions de présomption
d'innocence de nécessité de
protéger les les les jeunes qui peuvent
être en contact avec des des
vamp alors c'est vrai que sur la phase
présententielle lorsqu'il y a une mise
en examen là j'ai envie de dire on voit
à peu près comment ça peut s'organiser
et pour le coup ça peut être très bien
cadré puisque donc il peut y avoir une
mise en examen sous contrôle judiciaire
avec des interdictions de rentrer en
contact des suspensions d'exercice des
interdictions d'exercices et cetera et
je pense que là pour le coup laissons au
magistrat le soin de gérer à à partir de
la mise en examen la situation
personnelle et professionnelle ou
l'engagement en tant que bénévole de la
personne qui fait l'objet de cette mise
en examen parce que soyons très
clair la personne en charge d'une
procédure administrative n'aura jamais
dans son dossier autant d'éléments que
pourrait avoir le jinstruction pour
analyser au mieux la situation et la
suivre au fil de
l'eau donc cette cette période là à
partir de la mise en examen pour moi
euh peut-être des choses à améliorer
mais ça va par contre c'est la période
d'avant zone grise
euh où là nous sommes dans le cadre
d'une enquête préliminaire et c'est vrai
qu'on peut s'émouvoir que du fait que un
président de club ne soit pas
avisé avant de découvrir dans la presse
mais il y a aussi des situations qui
nécessitent que le président de club ne
soit pas
avisé imaginons que dans le cas d'une
plainte on est des suspicis que le
président président du club est couvert
son éducateur sportif il faut surtout
pas qu'il soit avisé puisque dans le
cadre de l'enquête préliminaire on va
recueillir des éléments contre la
personne mise en cause mais aussi contre
la personne qui a pu être complice de
cette personne mise en cause donc c'est
là qu'on voit toute la difficulté à à à
œuvrer et articuler les procédures
disciplinaires la mise à l'abri d'une
victime supposée et le respect de de de
la présomption d'innocence et les
nécessités de l'enquête alors ma
question parce qu'il faut quand même que
je termine par une question
euh est-ce
que dans d'autres pays on a on a une
façon de traiter ces situations là on
sait qu'on est dans un système nous
inquisitoire est-ce que le système
accusatoire permet de mieux protéger les
intérêts des uns et des autres parce
qu'on voit bien quand même que là il
faut il faut qu'on aille plus loin dans
notre arsenal dans nos enquêtes dans nos
procédures pour arriver quand même à
aménager la nécessité de de de l'enquête
et et et la protection des des victimes
supposées euh je je suis sous sererment
je suis obligé de répondre je sais pas
mais mais je crois savoir qu'il y a une
commission d'enquête sur ce sujet
pourrait peut-être interroger un certain
nombre de d'intervenants étrangers pour
savoir comment ça se passe je je dire
deux choses pardon monsieur monsieur le
député Stéphane Mazard euh dans
l'exemple que vous prenez et vous dites
ouais imaginons parce que évidemment on
peut imaginer beaucoup de choses et et
et quand je dis il faut pas qu'il y ait
de systématisation de ces questions
d'information parce que je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises sans savoir que vous
prendriez cet exemple il est
particulièrement pertinent on est
toujours sur du cas par cas dans
l'exemple que vous donné il y a un petit
souci c'est que c'est dans la presse
quand même parce que tant qu'à ne pas le
dire parce que on envisage d'éventuell
complicité culpabilité des uns ou des
autres qui très choquant c'est que ce
soit dans la presse mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut laisser cette li liberté au
parquet et c'est une liberté entière
dans laquelle je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
le garde des saau ne peut pas intervenir
pour dire faut communiquer comme c comme
ça bien sûr mais faisons confiance au au
au procureur de la République qui savent
s'il est utile de communiquer ou ou ou
ou de ne pas ou de ne pas communiquer
pour le reste non ce qui se passe au
niveau européen je je sais pas mais je
pense qu'ils doivent être comme nous
dans une dualité qui est assez assez
complexe à régler le le disciplinaire et
et le et le et et le
pénal moi pour avoir été avocat très
très longtemps j'ai vu des situations
dans lesquelles
euh un juge d'instruction mettait en
examen un avocat lui interdisait
l'exercice alors que l'ordre n'avait pas
interdit l'exercice il y a eu d'ailleurs
toute une polémique et un certain nombre
de modifications textuelles qui sont
intervenues comment on fait c'est là
encore du cas par cas c'est extrêmement
compliqué à cela s'ajoute mais on l'a
tous dit je je je j'enfile des perles là
et vous vous me le pardonnerez mais la
question de la présomption d'innocence
évidemment qui est au cœur d'une
réflexion comme celle que nous que nous
conduisons non je ne sais pas ce qui se
passe à l'étranger sur ces questions je
peux évidemment me renseigner contacter
quelques magistrat de liaison faire
parvenir une note rapide si si vous le
si vous le souhaitez madame la
rapporteur souhaite
réagir merci merci beaucoup je vais
juste préciser la question de
l'automatisation euh en réalité ce qu'on
a pu constater c'est
que la les procédures disciplinaires
sont extrêmement lourdes pour les
fédérations et toutes les fédérations
d'ailleurs n'ont pas la même capacité à
pouvoir intervenir à pouvoir traiter ces
cas lorsqu'ils arrivent au sein de leur
fédération parce que vous avez des
fédérations qui sont très grosse avec
énormément de personnes et de bénévoles
qui sont de licenciés et vous en avez
des plus petites la difficulté c'est
quand on a euh parfois des personnes qui
au vu de la lourdeur et du et de ce que
ça demande est- ce que ça nécessite ben
en fait le fait que ça ne soit pas
obligatoire préfère se dire je ne traite
pas je ne traite pas parce que je je
n'ai pas les capacités de le faire parce
que finalement ce n'est pas obligatoire
parce que parce que il y a plein de
raisons qui font en réalité aujourd'hui
que les affaires ne sont pas ne sont pas
traités à cette hauteur et donc le fait
de l'inscrire et d'ailleurs je je
précise bien quand il pèse des indices
graves et concordants c'estàdire qu'on
est vraiment sur des affaires sur
lesquelles il y a soit plusieurs
victimes soit des témoignages qui sont
on avance quand même assez vite et c'est
vrai que dans ces cas-là on a eu parfois
du mal à comprendre pourquoi euh
certaines fédérations avaient mis
plusieurs années parfois à prendre des
sanctions disciplinaires ou même
d'ailleurs quand ils étaient informés y
compris par des entraîneurs qui avaient
été licenciés puis recruté de nouveau
dans certains clubs alors même qu'on
connaît leur passé et qu' a pas eu de
sanctions qui ont été prises voilà c'est
c'est juste à ce niveau-là c'est vrai
que peut-être que le fait de le
formaliser permettrait de simplifier les
choses pour les présidents de
fédération si pardon je je peux dire de
mots madame la Présidente merci beaucoup
je je je voudrais rajouter deux mots à
ce que à ce que nous avons dit là euh
d'abord il y a un réseau européen de
magistrats responsable du sport qui
s'appelle le réseau mars qui a été mis
en place par le Conseil de l'Europe et
d'ailleurs je suis intervenu il y a de
cela quel en septembre
euh dernière réunion du réseau mars en
septembre et c'est un réseau de
magistrat qui permet une coordination
des actions judiciaires en matière de
lutte
contre contre le le dopage et ça nous
intéresse là davantage à cet instant
contre euh pour la prévention de la
répression des violences physiques et
sexuelles dans le sport sur ces
questions là je je je reviens à
l'instant monsieur le député Mazard si
vous souhaitez on active les magistrats
liaison et on vous fait un point complet
madame la Présidente sur la façon dont
on envisage les poursuites
disciplinaires et les poursuites
judiciaires dans chez nos partenaires
européens on va
prendre certain nombre de de pays euh
qui nous entourent par exemple
euh sur ces délais je je je c'est mon
mantra mais vous dire que j'exagère
peut-être mais la façon d'aller plus
vite c'est évidemment de renforcer les
moyens bon c'est c'est para une évidence
mais parfois il est utile de de les
rappeler et enfin je veux vous dire que
il y
a la création d'un
magistrat référent
sport
euh ça a été mis en place par une
dépêche signée en en octobre
2021 et au jour d'aujourd'hui madame la
Présidente la quasi totalité des
parquets
c'est-à-dire on a 164 parquets dans
notre pays la quasi totalité des
parquets ont procédé à la désignation
d'un magistrat référent sport et il est
évidemment l'interlocuteur privilégié
des instances sportives locales et il
assure bien sûr le suivi des procédures
judiciaires relatives
euh notamment au sujet au sujet qui nous
qui nous occupe je je voulais le
préciser parce que ça signifie quand
même que il y a une évidemment une une
prise en compte dans dans dans toutes
les strates spécialisation des
enquêteurs ueaped je je je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure meilleure prise en compte des
des victimes et euh euh là on est sur
des victimes j'allais dire spécifiques
pardon d'utiliser ce mot il n'est pas
adéquat mais il y a aussi une prise en
compte dans les
différents dans les différentes
juridictions de la nécessité de mieux
articuler et de mieux
fluidifier la relation entre les
fédérations les clubs et la
justice al justement pour continuer sur
la lourdeur que peuvent rencontrer
parfois certaines fédérations
lors des différentes auditions pareil a
été avancé par
certains l'idée de créer une autorité
administrative indépendante chargé de
veiller à l'éthique du sport et à la
lutte contre les VSS et les
discriminations qu'en
pensez-vous madame la rapporteur que ça
mérite
réflexion pardon de ne pas réagir dans
l'immédiaté autorité administrative
indépendante c'est une idée
que que que vous évoquez aucune raison a
priori de dire non
euh je pense que ça se ça se réfléchit
ça s'analyse ça se regarde de près et et
de la façon la plus sérieuse qui soit
oui je précise que ce qui été équé c'est
sur le même modèle que sur le
dopage madame Claudia rouo
oui merci Monsieur le Ministre bonjour
Alors moi j'ai je vais poser quelques
questions parce que je ne reprendrai pas
la parole alors la première on a
auditionné enfin Madame la Présidente et
Madame la rapporteur ont auditionné une
une association qui s'appelle rouge
direct une association qui s'appelle
route rouge direct et qui lutte contre
l'homophobie et euh c'est pour aborder
le fait des procureurs donc euh il y a
eu des incidents très grave à marseille-
lon des accidents de foot enfin vous
êtes tous au courant et euh le le
président de l'association nous disait
que le procureur avait gardé euh des
faits de d'agression puisqueil y avait
eu des cillassage du du bus des fait euh
de de cris de racisme dans l'hémicycle
mais euh il y avait des champs que nous
avons entendu dans l'audition
comment ah
non je devrais sortir un peu plus de
cette émicycle dans dans le stade et
notamment des champs homophobes donc je
je vais pas les rapporter mais on a très
bien entendu c'était tout un tout un
cœur qui chantait des des cris
homophobes et le le procureur n'a pas
retenu ces cris homophobes donc là on
est tous un peu interrogatif dans une
autre situation où le président de
l'association non le le juriste de
l'association fait un signalement auprès
du Procureur pour des relations
sexuelles entre un juge arbitre lors
d'un stage auprès d'une jeune fille de
16 ans il y a plus de 5 ans de
différence d'âge le procureur annonce
que il va classer s suite parce qu'il y
a pas de plainte de la famille il
s'approprie pas de ce dossier-là alors
madame la Présidente et Madame la
rapporteur ont le le dossier et puis de
de de ce constat qu'on a eu quasiment à
chaque audition c'est le classement sans
suite le non lieu le classement sans
suite le non lieu et qui finalement
décourage les fédérations voir les clubs
d'aller plus loin parce que lorsqu'il y
a du disciplinaire et bien quelquefois
il faut rétablir les salaires enfin il y
a il y a du prudem mal derrière et
finalement l'association ou la
fédération se trouve pénalisée pensant
bien faire donc il y a un sujet quand
même sur ces classements sans suite et
pour finir juste le dernier puisque
c'est une une personne qu'on a
auditionné que j'ai rencontré ensuite et
bien son son affaire a été classée sans
suite mais elle n'a jamais été informée
donc elle était toujours dans l'attente
donc on a un sujet quand même au niveau
de de la justice et est-ce qu'on peut
quand même améliorer ces
situationsl madame la députée
on d'abord je je je crois savoir que
parmi les exemples que vous nous donnez
il y a encore des des affaires qui sont
en
cours l'histoire de Marseille je sais
pas
si est terminée bon donc ce qui dé facto
m'interdit d'en dire davantage mais en
tout état de cause mais inquiétez pas je
vais pas me retrancher derrière ça pour
vous
répondre mais en tout état de cause et
même si cette affaire av connu son
épilogue
la justice de ce pays elle est
indépendante qu'est-ce que ça signifie
l'indépendance au
fond signifie naturellement que c'est
pas l'exécutif qui décroche son
téléphone pour dire au procureur faites
C faites ça ce qui nous ferait basculer
dans quelque chose qui n'aurait plus
grand chose à voir avec l'État de droit
et la démocratie des pays où ça se
pratique chez nous fort heureusement
c'est pas comme ça que ça se pratique
parfois l'indépendance elle a pour
corolaire des décisions qui nous
semblent comment pu je le dire
saugrenu et c'est un mot doucement
euphémique bien mais précisons plusieurs
chose d'abord que nous n'avons pas tous
les éléments d'un
dossier et que naturellement
l'indépendance a pour corollaire parfois
ces décisions qu'on a du mal à
comprendre bon sans avoir tous les
éléments je le redis hein parce que le
commentaire d'une décision de justice à
la
hâte n'est pas toujours le commentaire
le plus le plus objectif qui
soit pourquoi des classements sans suite
ce que l'on doit espérer ce que l'on
espère ce qui est la très très très très
grande majorité des situations c'est que
la seule boussole du procureur c'est les
faits et le droit bon et que un
classement sans
suite ça n'est pas une décision qui est
prise au doigt mouillés
alors qu'il y ait dans l'histoire de
notre justice des classements sans suite
injustifié voire injusticiable prix en
toute indépendance ça s'appelle la
liberté juridictionnelle peut-être sans
doute même pour autant moi ces affaires
que vous évoquez je ne les connais pas
je ne peux pas les commenter et que
puis-je ajouter à cela c'est que en
revanche un classement sans suite ça se
notifie car plutôt que de dans dans une
critique à serbe d'une décision qui
serait rendue et que notre bon sens nous
interdirait de comprendre ce que l'on
dit quand on parle d'indépendance de la
justice c'est qu'il y a des voies de
recours et en particulier un classement
sans suite peut faire l'objet d'un
réexamen c'est un classement sans suite
procureur de la République par le
procureur général en revanche si vous me
dites que on n pas notifié un classement
sans
suite là il y a quelque chose qui va pas
bien parce que pour critiquer une
décision encore faut-il qu'elle a été
portée à la connaissance du justiciable
s'il en a pas connaissance il a du mal à
la contester et il ne peut que la
contester par les VO les voies de droit
classiques donc voilà ce que ce que ce
que je peux répondre sur ces questions
de de d'homophobie exprimé et cetera on
a pris un certain nombre de
disposition de longue date déjà enfin de
longue date il y a de cela déjà
plusieurs années fait une réunion je je
je me souviens à beauovau avec Gérald
armanin
avec Madame Mar Mar céanous avec
différents président de de de grands
club et nous avions décidé d'un certain
nombre de mesur notamment les
interdictions de stade d'une durée
minimale de 5 ans
maximal pardonnez-moi moi je le dis j'en
ai ras le bol d'entendre ses
comportements
euh ces ces vociférations
euh ces
cris homophobe ça n'a rien à voir dans
le sport
euh j'ai vu récemment ça m'a beaucoup
touché le témoignage de Basil
Bolly qui nous a permis d'être champion
d'Europe quand même hein hein euh et il
expliquait comment il vivait euh les
crit de singe c'est de ça dont on parle
qui lui était adressé le racisme
l'homophobie ça n'a rien à voir dans un
stade et moi je suis tout à fait prêt je
le dis je je je je l'ai évoqué ce matin
avec avec mes équipes là à ce que les
types qui se comportent comme ça soient
définitivement interdit de de de
stade voilà parce que il y a des gens
qui comprennent rien à rien d'ailleurs
je sais pas si ces gens-là aiment le
sport c'est pas possible d'aimer le
sport et puis d'être d'avoir ces ces ces
attitudes de discrimination le sport
c'est le contraire de ça le sport c'est
ce qui unit les gens c'est ce qui voilà
donc je je suis prêt à ce qu'on regarde
ça moi je je n'ai pas de de à priori de
comment dirais-je de de de ligne
infranchissable sur la façon dont on
règle ces questions c'est ce que je vais
faire d'ailleurs je vais très
prochainement
envoyer des gens de chez nous du
ministère en anglre TER parce qu'ils ont
connu un
houliganisme d'une incroyable
oui c'était une terreur voilà ils ont
réussi à régler
cela avec des mesures drastiques bah
s'il faut aller copier les mesures
drastiques on va y aller c'est c'est
infernal tout ça je je je j'avais
d'ailleurs souhaité je je je je vous
l'indique je souhaite qu'on le mette en
place que l'on rappelle sur la sur les
billets voyez les
la billetterie les les les termes du
Code pénal en la matière voyez que que
vous jetiez une fusée un projectile sur
le stade que vous balanciez des cris de
singe à un joueur de couleur que je sais
pas quoi que vous criez ce que on
entend dans certains stades ça va stop
stop et stop donc informer davantage
ceux qui ne le serait pas déjà
bon puis franchement il y a aussi tous
ces gamins là qui viennent au stade avec
leurs pères avec avec leur le le le leur
famille là voilà et et et qui entendent
des trucs pareils enfin c'est
l'antisport par excellence donc moi je
le dis je n'ai
aucune aucune ligne rouge
infranchissable là-dessus et s'il faut
être plus sévère on proposera un certain
nombre de choses de de ce point de vue
voilà
oui peut-être sur ce sujet de justement
de la lutte contre l'homophobie des du
racisme dans dans les stades nous on
avait euh une question sur la question
de l'interdiction des stades euh pour
euh pour les personnes qui sont qui ont
été identifi euh comme pouvant étant
être problématique je pense à la
question du match omol notamment où les
supporters étit interdit de stade enfin
d'ailleurs c'était ils étaient
identifiés en tout cas pour certains
d'entre eux comme étant interdit de
stade à Lyon mais ils ont pu aller à
Marseille donc là c'est comment est-
qu'on agit à ce niveau-là pour que
l'interdiction soit globale et non pas
juste une interdiction étion de
billetterie à l'échelle d'un club et la
la deuxième question c'est au moment où
on a auditionné ici je pense à
l'association des supporters sur le foot
il y a eu beaucoup de débats et
notamment pendant longtemps je pense que
pour certains ça existe encore le fait
de considérer que les champs homophobes
font partie du folklore dans le dans
dans le foot et donc dans les stades et
et d'ailleurs l'association nous a dit
oui mais vous comprenez pour que un acte
soit condam
en tant qu'acte homophobe il faut qu'il
y ait
l'intentionnalité dans les propos qui
sont tenus donc à partir du moment où on
est dans le cadre du stade dans le cadre
d'un champ et cetera et cetera c'était
un peu ça le le débat qu'on qu'on avait
eu et donc comment est-ce qu'on peut
renforcer peut-être de ce point de
vue-là et renforcer le dispositif qui
existe pour dire que non en fait un ce
n'est pas du folklore et que deux c'est
pas une question d'intentionalité mais à
partir du moment où on tient des propos
homophobe ils sont
homophobes ben je suis d'accord à à 100
% avec ce que vous venez dire le
folklore alors ça justifie tout le
folcl
non il a il y a des mots qui sont
clairement porteur de leur sens non bah
oui voilà ben stop et si c'est une
question de folklore faut changer de
folklore qu'est-ce que voulez que je
vous
dise non non mais le président il dit ce
qu'il veut mais le garde des saut il
pense que quand on crie un certain
nombre de choses on va pas les répéter
ici on voit de quoi il s'agit he c'est
un volume lexical assez restreint
d'ailleurs hein on a vite à l'idée et
puis on entend les choses bon
euh non c'est pas du folklore c'est
écoutez alors alors je vais vous
injurier c'est un folklore Mo tout va
bien enfin ça n'a aucun sens tout ça
faut être sérieux quand même et puis et
puis écoutez-moi bien le folklore c'est
fait aussi pour réunir les gens quand
vous regardez pas vous allez à Perpignan
voyz des G gens danser la sardane c'est
du folklore ça réjouit les gens mais là
ça blesse les gens ça blesse les gamins
ça blesse les gens qui qui est
homosexuel qui est un homme de couleur
une femme de couleur enfin il faut il
faut arrêter avec ces trucs là du
folklore pourquoi pas une ponctuation
alors d'ailleurs pour certains de ces
mots je veux vous dire madame la députée
pardon je je suis allé un peu vite on va
parfois un peu vite s'agissant des
violences
sexuelles notamment j'ai pris une
circulaire en 2021 en février très
précisément pour demander au procureur
d'informer systématiquement les victimes
d'un classement donc si là vous avez un
cas particulier où il y a pas eu de
d'information je je le dis c'est un
dysfonctionnement de la même façon
d'ailleurs j'avais demandé mais je l'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure dans le discours
mais je le redis à ce que quand les
faits apparaissent prescrits un
professionnel de la justice assez vite
les choses c'est prescrit demandez quand
même qu'il y ait une enquête pourquoi
parce que derrière des faits
prescrits peuvent se cacher des faits
qui ne le sont pas et c'est d'ailleurs
tous les mécanismes qu'on a mis en place
ensuite de prescriptions allongées
permettant d'aller appréhender un
certain nombre de faits fusil prescrit
quand il y a un auteur unique parce que
vous
aviez CQ victime qui avait subi la même
chose qui se retrouvaient dans le même
procès quatre d'entre elles était que
témoin et la dernière était considérée
au sens judiciaire du terme comme une
victime on a travaillé sur ces questions
pour que tout le monde évidemment puisse
être appréhendé en qualité de
victime monsieur Stéphane
bchou merci madame la présidente
monsieur le
ministre je je
voudrais même si vous avez explicité un
certain nombre d'éléments je je revient
euh sur la sur les questions euh euh du
début de de de l'audition
euh sanction euh sanction judiciaire
sanction euh sanction administrative
parce que comme ça a été rappelé euh par
les par les précédents orateurs
effectivement c'est un peu le nœud
gordien de de nos auditions c'està-dire
que on a beaucoup entendu euh alors là
on on évoque on on on tourne autour mais
au fond
on on ne parvient pas on est vraiment
sur une sur une ligne de crête et on ne
parvient pas malheureusement à à trouver
le le le le le bon outil bien que nous
ayons un un arsenal juridique assez
développé en en la matière et et c'est
vrai que cette question de
la présomption d'innocence qui n'est
absolument pas remise en cause bien
évidemment
elle est une forme de de de de de voile
derrière lequel se
cache pardon de le dire comme ça mais
beaucoup de responsables que nous avons
que nous avons auditionné avec
évidemment là
aussi une forme d'épé de d'amoclesè qui
repose sur sur leur sur leur tête pour
certains avec un risque avec un risque
de
recours non pas que je veuille que vous
soyez répétitif dans les propos que vous
avez pu déjà tenir mais
éventuellement éventuellement monsieur
le
ministre mais voilà non mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a une forme de frustration je
pense collective et et particulièrement
individuelle à se dire que au final il y
a pas on va pas y arriver quoi tout le
enfin on va pas y arriver je je suis
d'un naturel plutôt optimiste mais mais
mais quand même de de de de se dire c
ces ces mesures conservatoires euh pour
reprendre l'expression de Madame la
rapporteur pour des euh pour des
des mince je trouve pas mon mot mais
c'est pas grave pour des soupçons graves
et concordants des indices pardon merci
monsieur le député Mazar pour des
indices des indices graves et
concordants comment est-ce qu'on peut
articuler
ministère fédération ministère de la
Justice ministère des Sports direction
des sports euh fédération sportive pour
que au moins cette information
elle soit donnée parce queil y a à la
fois je pense de la part des
responsables des responsables des
présidents de fédération peut-être une
peur et et et aussi beaucoup de
mécnaissances beaucoup de mes
connaissances et pardon
euh là aussi j'entends votre votre
volonté de fermeté je passe sur l'autre
sujet des des comportements
discriminatoires dans les enceintes
sportives j'entends parfaitement votre
fermeté nous avons eu l'occasion par
exemple hier soir d'entendre le
président de la Ligue professionnelle de
football ce matin le président l'ancien
président de la Fédération Française de
Rugby qui sont qui sont sur la même
ligne et là aussi
euh il y a tout le monde veut prendre le
même
chemin mais on y est pas encore
donc voilà trois petits points de
suspension merci de nous merci de nous
donner avec la baguette magique que vous
n'avez pas quelques éléments de réponse
merci
beaucoup monsieur le député
bchou outre les qualités que je vous
connais et que nous vous reconnaissons
tous vous avez ajouté une forme de
presscience ou de médiumité là parce que
vous avez bien compris que j'allais
répéter ce que j'avais déjà dit mais je
veux le faire si je veux le faire je je
pense que puis alors je note que je note
que pour un optimiste vous dites qu'on y
arrivera pas heureusement que vous
n'êtes pas pessimiste mais euh comment
on peut comment on peut mieux articuler
tout ça bon l'exemple qui a été donné
tout à l'heure par Stéphane Mazard il il
est
éclairant de la nécessité de laisser au
au parquet le soin de communiquer ou de
ne pas communiquer en opportunité avec
les risques que ça peut comporter que
l'une des procédures viennent polluer
l'autre on a dit tout ça bon mais euh
euh
il faut que ça communique plus chaque
fois que possible voilà comment on
peut dire les choses me
semble-t-il la solution elle est dans
les
moyens moi vous savez je je j'ai dit mon
ambition c'est de réduire les délais
tous les délais de justice de les
diviser par de pourquoi on peut espérer
ça parce que on a mis en place de
nouvelles
procédures on est dans le ressort
réglementaire vous savez évidemment de
quoi je parle et puis on a donné
davantage de moyens donc pardon mais nos
compatriotes vont aussi être exigeants
avec cet argent public
octroyer à la justice de façon
historique ils vont aussi demander à ce
que il y ait un effort de tout le monde
et et c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'entends
de plus en plus dans la bouche de nos
magistrats bien sûr bien sûr donc avec
ces moyens on doit aller plus vite si on
va plus vite on passe du présententiel
au postsententiel plus rapidement et
naturellement en unique plus vite et on
prend un certain nombre de mesures
disciplinaires de de de de pour éviter
pour éviter des réitérations et puis on
infe les féd et les clubs
pardonnez-moi de condamnations intervenu
plus rapidement elle aussi et et et de
figè rempl plus rapidement bien sûr
parce que on veut accélérer tout
cela je veux rappeler là sur cette
histoire de de folklore parce que je
suis pas revenu de ça moi
hier au
Sénat la République et vous serez saisi
de ce texte a reconnu les Herms ses Herm
en
matière
d'homosexualité de condamnation des
homosexuels dans une période qui part de
de l'après-guerre à
82 ces milliers de gens qui ont été
condamnés dont l'honneur a é pardon pour
cette
expression euh que tout le monde connaît
et qui n'est pas de moi bien sûr dont
l'honneur a été livré aux chiens les les
familles bousculé bon et au fond l'idée
était de dire tous ensemble de façon
transpartisan que la République est
grande aussi quand elle reconnaît ses
erreurs voir ses fautes donc c'est pas
au moment où on fait ça que on va se
contenter d'une
explication de confort de folklore euh
il faut que ça s'arrête voilà et on
prendra les mesures me semble-t-il qui
s'impose d'ailleurs
euh ce qui est assez curieux c'est que
il y a il y a il y a des sports
collectifs on entend jamais ces
choses bon et des sports collectifs qui
se qui se qui se distinguent d'autres
par ces manifestations qui sont
insupportables et alors euh par exemple
pousser des cris de singe là dans une
tribune machin c'est du folklore ça
aussi ah bon bah non non non c'est c'est
discriminatoire c'est insultant c'est
raciste faut faut appeler les choses par
leur nom voilà V c'est V lanterne c'est
lanterne voilà ce que je peux vous
diredus alors dans le cadre de de nos
travaux on a pu constater dans les
différentes auditions un défaut de
signalement important de la part des
acteurs du monde sportif donc déjà
comment on peut y remédier parce que
tout cela contribue euh au sentiment
d'impunité qui a arégné pendant pendant
très longtemps on a ici eu l'occasion
d'auditionner plusieurs victimes qui
nous ont dit qu'elles avaient signalé
les faits parfois très longtemps avant 4
ans 5 ans avant et et pourtant il y a
rien qui s'est passé au sein de leur
club on a aussi parfois eu des
dirigeants ici de fédération qui nous
ont dit oui on avait entendu que il y
avait des bruits qui circulaient mais
ils n'ont jamais ouvert ni d'enquête
interne à leur club ni chercher à
comprendre ce qui se passait réellement
jusqu'à ce que les affaires finalement
atterrissent dans la presse et que là ça
soit des dépôts de plaintte qui a étai
faites donc on est très interrogatif 1
sur la méconnaissance de l'article 40
par les présidents de fédération et le
fait déjà pour certains d'entre eux ne
n'avaient même pas connaissance qu'il
pouvait
l'utiliser
et et la question qu'on s'est beaucoup
posée c'est quelles mesures peuvent être
prises à l'encontre d'un cadre en
l'absence d'un signalement d'ailleurs ça
peut être un cadre ou autre et par le
fait que alors je sais vous allez me
dire que ça existe mais mais ce n'est
pas mis en application aujourd'hui vous
avez des personnes qui n'ont pas signalé
dont on sait qu'elles n'ont pas signalé
qu'elles étaient informées et pour
lesquels il ne s'est rien passé et et
pareil pour les autres personnes par
qu'on parle des cadres mais finalement
toute personne qui est témoin d'une
agression sexuelle ou qui est informé de
fait et qui ne les signale pas devrait
avoir des comptes à rendre puisque moi
j'ai souvent l'occasion de dire quand on
ne signale pas c'est qu'on est complice
par son silence et donc dans ce cadre là
que pouvons nous faire pour avancer
là-dessus
communiquer puis ensuite je vais
répondre complètement à la à la
question intéressante que que que vous
me posez en en 2022 pardon je je je le
lis hein pardonnez-moi pour cette
lecture
91 personnes en 2022 ont été condamné
pour une infraction principale de non
dénonciation de crime ou pour non
dénonciation de mauvais traitement
privation agression ou atteinte sexuelle
infligé à un mineur 83 ont été étaé
condamné à une peine
d'emprisonnement et dans 14 cas cette
peine était ferme ou en partie ferme le
quantum moyen euh des peines prononcées
sélevant à 17 mois donc certaines
sévérité hein alors on a le fameux
article 40 mais euh il s'applique pas
pour tout le monde ne peut pas euh euh
comment dirais-je
euh s'approprier cet article mais il a
ensuite l'article
434-3 du code pénal qui oblige quiconque
ayant eu
connaissance de crime
délit concernant
des agression sexuelle ou atteinte
sexuelle infligé à des mineurs
obligation de dénoncer et celui qui
n'informe pas les autorités judiciaire
ou administrative
ou continue à ne pas les informer la
peine qui est couru je le rappelle est
une peine importante c'est 3 ans
d'emprisonnement 45000 € d'amende bon
comment je peux faire pour que ça
fonctionne mieux bah rappelez les textes
euh évidemment ce que ce que ce que nous
faisons et c'est aussi le rôle
d'ailleurs du magistrat référence sport
euh moi je peux pas aller au au
au-delà mais tout ça
voyez parlait tout à l'heure d'optimisme
de pessimisme je pense que il y a une
véritable prise en compte sociétale de
ces de ces phénomènes de de ces crimes
de de l'impérieuse nécessité de les de
les appréhender de les réprimer on aura
de plus en plus de paroles qui se qui se
libère c'est vrai dans ce domaine des
mineurs mais c'est vrai également dans
cette question cruciale pour nous les
violences intrafamiliales vous avez
quand même des gens qui qui qui savent
que que dans certains
couples la femme est régulièrement
battue qu'elle fait l'objet de violence
et cetera qui est bon ok et les paroles
aujourd'hui se libèrent parce
que je pense que c'est toute la société
qui prend conscience
que que ces crimes il faut les éradiquer
de de façon de façon
définitive qu'ils sont indignes d'un
grand pays comme le nôtre donc nous
avons l'arsenal juridique là complet à
la fois l'article 40 qui est un vieux
texte et le le le
434-3 qui fait obligation de de de
dénoncer euh et encore une fois une
relation que je
souhaite fluide entre entre les parquets
entre le monde de la justice et le monde
du sport pour le dire comme ça avec des
magistrats référents qui qui ont aussi
pour mission de d'informer euh les
différents dirigeants sportifs de
l'existence de ces textes et des
obligations qui sont celles de de de
toutes personnes ayant ayant
connaissance de d'infraction de cette
nature notre collègue Monsieur François
pman
oui monsieur le ministre d'abord merci
pour vos précisions notamment lors de
votre sur une des premières questions
sur la difficulté évidemment qu'il y a
entre la dualité entre disciplinaire et
judiciaire je reviens sur sur un élément
que vous avez mentionné puisqu'on a
parlé du football et du phénomène du
houliganisme bon
euh il est vrai qu'il y a des groupes de
supporters qui sont coutumiers du fait
d'insulte raciste homophobe mais il est
vrai aussi qu'il y a des groupes de
supporters qui luttent contre de tes
insultes et que ça peut concerner aussi
des
individus isolés que ça ne concerne
malheureusement pas que le football il y
a beaucoup d'autres sports comme le
rugby et autres qui sont qui sont
touchés moi j'aurais tout de même une
une question c'est que il y a le travail
de fond qui a à faire dans toutes les
fédérations il y a les les sanctions qui
doivent tomber puisque ce sont des
délits il y a aussi la symbolique que
représente le sport aujourd'hui dans
notre société les sportives et les
sportifs et à ce titre moi je j'aurais
une une interrogation est-ce que vous
vous sentez à l'aise quand par exemple
monsieur
Darmanin va prendre un joueur de foot
pour le citer Karim Benzema et dire
qu'il est affilié au Frères musulmans et
ainsi attiser aussi quelque chose qui
n'est pas sain à mon avis
d'instrumentaliser là en l'occurrence un
joueur de foot mais j'aurais pu prendre
d'autres exemples tel joueur ne chante
pas la Marseillaise et cetera ça remonte
à Michel Platini et j'aurais aimé votre
votre avis sur sur le sujet est-ce qu'il
y a pas une précaution des politiques et
je me mets dedans puisque j'en fais
partie à ne pas instrumentaliser cette
question là je vous
remercie non je veux simplement vous
répondre qu'on est un peu hors sujet
pardonnez-moi
moi je viens pas ici faire un exercice
de sémantique euh
oui je pense que on est en sujet et
qu'il n'y a sans doute pas de hasard à
cela tu veux que j'engè sur ça c'est
ça ok alors euh peut-être je vais
reprendre sur d'autres propositions qui
ont été faites dans le cadre des travaux
de cette commission
euh la première est
l'imprescriptibilité des crimes sexuels
sur commis sur mineurs donc on a aussi
eu l'occasion d'entendre Jean-Marc
Sauvet qui nous a indiqué que cela
n'était pas souhaitable en raison de la
difficulté d'établir la matérialité des
faits des dizaines d'années après
et donc pareil on voudrait peut-être
vous entendre autour de de de ce débat
sur l'imprescriptibilité la deuxième est
la reconnaissance de l'amnésie
traumatique qui a également été portée à
notre connaissance dans le cadre de
cette commission d'enquête euh donc
voilà peut-être sur ces deux
propositions monsieur le
ministre euh sur l'amnésie traumatique
je voudrais vous répondre je ne suis pas
scientifique et que il y a un certain
nombre de travaux dont j'ai pris
connaissance évidemment euh qui sont
discutés dans la communauté
scientifique il m'est difficile
évidemment de de de vous donner sur
cette question un avis tranché sur la
question de la prescription c'est un
sujet que je je connais bien d' parce
que j'ai été évidemment invoé longtemps
et lorsque anque billon la
sénatrice
a présenté le le la proposition de loi
qui a été votée très très
largement j'ai beaucoup consulté et j'ai
reçu beaucoup d'associations des des des
victimes et je voudrais vous dire que la
question est infiniment complexe euh et
voilà les éléments de de de complexités
les plus les plus saillants si j'ose
dire euh la première difficulté est
celle qu'évoque le président
sauvé qui est celle de la preuve que
reste-t-il d'une
preuve 40 ans
après et quel procès euh peut-on
envisager
entre une victime qui serait
alors une vieille dame ou un vieux
monsieur très vieille dame très vieux
monsieur et un
accusé
qui le temps passe de façon écipolante
pour tout le monde serait un très vieux
monsieur ou une très vieille dame
qu'est-ce qui reste qu'est-ce que l'on
fait de ça est-ce que les espérances
moment que suscite pour une victime pour
une plaignante le dépôt d'une plainte ne
risque pas d'être déçu par une décision
qui ne pourrait pas être une décision de
culpabilité par exemple s'il ne reste
rien ça c'est une vraie difficulté au
fond le procès il est pas fait pour
faire du mal à une victime
euh voilà le le le le premier écueil si
j'ose dire il faut il faut être
très très nuancé sur ces questions le le
deuxième il est de cet ordre parmi t
ceux que j'ai rencontré certains m'ont
dit que des victimes souhaitaent
exprimer les choses mais après que la
prescription e été acquise parce qu'elle
souhaitait dire les choses mais ne
voulait pas d'un procès ça s'entend et
ça se respecte alors quel est le
pourcentage de victimes qui sont dans
cet état d' esprit à vrai dire je n'en
sais strictement rien mais ça doit être
entendu et je veux ajouter enfin mais ça
vous le savez déjà puisque vous êtes
parlementaire que les prescriptions ont
d'ors et déjà été allongées au travers
d'un certain nombre de
textes voilà ce que Madame la rapporteur
je je je peux vous
répondre alors plusieurs fédérations
sportives se constituent parti partie
civil lors des procédures pénal initié
par des victimes de violence certaines
fédérations ont inscrit cette
possibilité dans leur statut mais toutes
ne le font pas systématiquement face à
l'ampleur du phénomène des violences
dans le sport et du grand nombre de
victimes comment pourrait-on améliorer
l'accompagnement des victimes par ces
fédérations sportive je précise aussi
que certaines fédérations ont tenté de
se porter partiseriville ça a été refusé
donc elles ont d insister euh pour
obtenir le droit d'être partie civile
donc voilà là-dessus aussi comment
est-ce qu'on peut avancer et faciliter
les choses pour que les fédérations
accompagnent les victimes quand ellees
décident de porter
plantes pardon pardon c'est moi qui suis
auditionné et et je ne l'oublie pas mais
euh j'aimerais savoir où on a euh
considéré que l'intervention d'une
fédération était irrecevable que l'on
puisse regarder ça puce que les
conditions de recevabilité euh de de de
l'action civile euh sont définis sont
connus
euh Code de Procédure euh
pénal est-ce que sans inverser les
choses vous pourriez me communiquer des
éléments là-dessus que je puisse faire
regarder de façon très précise à quelle
fédération on a dit non pour quelle
raison voilà je crois que de mémoire
c'est l'article 2 du Code de Procédure
qui définit la façon d'intervenir et la
constitution de parti civile d'une
association je j'aimerais en savoir
davantage mais le sujet mérite
évidemment que qu'on le creuse et qu'on
règle la
question ah pardon on vous communiquera
je je veux pas dire de bêtises parce que
j'ai en tête la fédération mais on vous
communiquera l'affaire enfin le dossier
et le nom de la fédération en question
qui effectivement a dû faire la demande
une deuxième fois en fait ils ont dû
faire appel pour obtenir le le droit oui
au bout de la deuxiè
fois est-ce que je une question
textuelle ou est-ce que la procédure a
été mal introduite je je je n'en sais
rien si si non si vous pouviez me le
dire si c'est une question textuelle pas
trop comment on pourrait refuser à une
fédération d'intervenir parce que on
incite au contraire les fédérations à
intervenir et à se constituer partie
civile donc si vous le voulez bien
l'impératif m'est interdit mais
dites-moi je je je suis curieux de
cela au cours de son audition Monsieur
Jean-Marc Sauvet a déclaré qu'au-delà de
la reconnaissance se pose la question de
la réparation
la commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église la sias donc a
effectué un travail remarquable qui a
notamment conduit à la création d'une
grille d'évaluation transversale pour
l'ensemble des victimes tenant compte
des conséquences dommageables des actes
commis à votre sens ce travail
pourrait-il être transposé au champ du
sport longtemps marqué par une rude
hertin je le dis d'autant plus que les
victimes qu'on a eu qu'on a entendu dans
le cadre de cette commission alors déjà
pour la plupart d'entre elles ont mis
énormément temp et c'est pour ça qu'on a
évoqué la question de l'amnésie
traumatique à pouvoir témoigner de ce
qu'elles avaient vécu quand elles
étaient plus jeunes et et notamment très
jeunes pour certaines d'entre elles mais
elles ont aussi pour certaines d'entre
elles fait part du fait qu'elles
n'avaient pas eu le sentiment d'avoir
d'avoir eu ce statut de victime en fait
cette reconnaissance de victime donc
voilà comment est-ce qu'on peut avancer
aussi
là-dessus je ne sais pas si si la grille
qui a été proposée par le président
sauvé est transposable au monde
sportif parce
que bon le le qu'est-ce qu' a proposé
qu'est-ce qui a été mis en place à la
suite du rapport sauvé c'est confier un
mécanisme
d'indemnisation des victimes d'abord à
un organe indépendant établissement d'un
mode de calcul
spécifique la difficulté là c'est que
les auteurs d' d'infraction sexuelle
dans le milieu
sportif n'agissent pas pour le compte
d'une personne juridique unique donc
c'est une des différences majeur et la
question de l'indemnisation disonsle des
préjudices subis par les enfants
victimes va bien audelà du seul domaine
du sport et mon ministère participe
actuellement un groupe de travail sur
l'indemnisation des victimes
d'infraction sexuell voilà ce que à ce
stade je peux vous dire
sur cette
question les les conclusions de ce
travail madame la rapporteur conclusions
de ce travail ce travail pardonnez-moi
seront rendu en en
2024 peut-être sur le fichier justement
le le le fichier figes on a des
représentants d'association luttant
contre les violence sur mineurs qui ont
réclamé la possibilité de consulter ce
fichier ou à défaut d'instituer un
référent figess par département qu'elle
pourrait consulter afin de faciliter
leur travail de prévention que
pensez-vous d'une telle
proposition euh la consultation des
fichiers c'est quelque chose vous
l'imaginez qui n'est pas simple à régler
hein non
euh pour des tas de raisons qui tiennent
d'ailleurs
aux règles qui sont les nôtres en
matière de de de liberté individuelle
évidemment
hein bon les données qui sont enregistré
par essence et par définition sont des
données qui sont des données sensibles
et certaines personnes sont inscrites au
fichier alors qu'elles ne sont pas
encore définitivement condamnées et
qu'elles sont simplement mises en examen
et là bien sûr nous ne pouvons que
réfléchir en terme bien sûr de
présomption d'innocence bon les
collectivités locales n'ont pas un accès
direct au
figes
euh moi
il me paraît pas euh opportun s réserve
d'une réflexion mais on a déjà eu ces
ces ces réflexions à plusieurs reprises
au Parlement
euh de modifier les équilibres qui sont
ceux que nous que nous avons mais la
désignation au sein des préfectures d'un
référent figès est une piste qui mérite
d'être explorée pour être plus
court ça mérite
réflexion et et elle aura lieu
évidemment il faut juste voilà éteindre
le micro Monsieur Philippe Astruc donc
procureur de la République de Rennes a
préconisé la réintroduction du
consentement dans le code pénal en en
proposant de préciser que tout acte de
nature sexuelle suppose un consentement
donner librement qu'en
pensez-vous c'est un sujet européen
aussi vous le savez
bon les réflexions se poursuivent sur
ces
questions le droit français réprime met
à l'évidence le le viol
euh la répression de ce crime a fait
l'objet d'un certain nombre
de de renforcements tout à fait légitime
et
opportun voilà ce que je peux dire à ce
stade une question monsieur Stéphane
Mazard
le micro le garde des saut euh désolé de
de revenir un petit peu en arrière et de
revenir sur ce folklore qui n'en est pas
d'un et quand on a l'habitude d'aller
dans un stade monsieur le gardess saau
on est quand même témoin régulièrement
de délits
commis devant nous en flagrance et qui
pour le coup il faut le dire quandes ne
sont pas ne sont pas poursuivis et et
malgré la volonté affichée de tout les
acteurs du sport ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par mon collègue Stéphane bchou
quand on auditionne monsieur la brune
quand on auditionne ce matin monsieur la
porte tout le monde nous dit mais nous
tolérance zéro quoi il faut y aller il
faut il faut les
poursuivre
alors quelle est la difficulté
c'est est-ce que il est difficile
d'aller appréhender la responsabilité
individuelle du fauteur de trouble euh
bien que quand même objectivement
aujourd'hui avec les moyens de
surveillance qu'on a dans les stades on
peut assez facilement aller identifier
le type qui a chanté ou ou ou ou crier
ou ou fait un cri de singe et
franchement on peut on peut le
poursuivre je pense assez assez
facilement est-ce qu'il faut peut-être
avoir une autre stratégie de
responsabiliser ceux qui sont en charge
d'organiser un spectacle sportif avec
une responsabilité pénale de la personne
morale
organisatrice le
club voilà mais mais aujourd'hui on a
une volonté des acteurs du sport on a
une volonté politique
indéniable et on
a tous les weekends des délits qui sont
commis devant les yeux les yeux de nos
enfants et et devant nous-mêmes et on a
on a on a quand même un vrai
sujet on a des enseignes sportives dans
lesqueles gardau on a souvent les
représentants du parquet puisqu'ils
viennent assurer effectivement la
sécurisation et voir comment le le
dispositif de sécurité est mis en place
donc on a faut le dire sous les yeux du
procureur de la République lui-même des
délits qui sont commis en flagrance et
qui ne sont pas poursuivis alors c'est
peut-être la culture du
folklore mais si c'est le cas il faut en
sortir et vite c'est des problèmes de se
ménager la preuve d'engorger les
tribunaux avec des poursuites
individuelles est-ce qu'on est pas sur
des délits qui pourent faire l'objet
d'une amende forfaitaire j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas il faut trouver les
moyens aujourd'hui d'aller d'aller les
cogn là où ça le
mérite merci d'abord monsieur le député
Stéphane Mazard de rappeler que les
référents sport vous savez de quoi vous
parlerz je pense que vous les vous les
avez vu sont présents euh derrière
j'allais dire les
écrans au poste de commandement pour
vérifier ce qui se passe dans le stade
bon quand même ça c'est une amélioration
considérable bon ensuite vous me dites
responsabilisation des présidents euh de
au club et cetera et cetera bon mais il
y a ceux qui disent sans aucune ambiguïé
ces comportements on veut plus les voir
il faut prendre les mesures puis ceux
qui vous disent c'est du
folklore donc il y en a qui sont faciles
à responsabiliser ils le sont déjà et et
et d'autres qui n'ont pas entendu un
certain nombre de
choses que tout un chacun mériterait
d'entendre voilà comment je peux
m'exprimer sur cette question euh je
veux revenir une toute petite seconde en
arrière si vous me permettez ce petit
petit ce petit
flashback
euh sur la répression des viols dans
dans notre pays je quand même dire vous
donner un certain nombre de chiffres
euh d'abord la législation française est
une des plus répressives d'Europe si ce
n'est la plus répressive d'Europe les
crimes de viol c'est 15 ans de prison
jusqu'à la réclusion criminelle en
perpétuité au gré naturellement des
circonstances aggravantes qui peut peu
être retenu je vais vous donner les
chiffres
là des condamnations et
cetera le nombre d'affaires de viol ou
d'agression sexuelle signalé au parquet
a doublé entre 2017 et 2021 bon c'est
qu'ensuite il faut remonter tous les
chiffres et cetera donc je je je c'est
pas aujourd'hui mais en tous les cas ça
n'est pas un ça ne se ça ne sont pas ça
n'est pas ce que je vais vous dire euh
des chiffres qui sont qui sont à la
baisse au contraire
2017 signalement au parquet 20000
affaires on est àprès de 40000 en 2021
nombre de condamnation pour viol a
augmenté de 40 % sur la même période
2017-
2021 et
98 % des peines
prononcé sont des peines de 11 ans de
prison en
moyenne en
moyenne si on compare l'évolution des
peines prononcées je peux vous dire que
on est sur de l'aggravation ce qui me
permet de répondre j'ai déjà fait une
centaine de fois mais il n'est pire sour
que celui qui ne veut pas entendre que
les peines sont de plus en plus lourdes
il s'agisse d'ailleurs des peines
correctionnelles
mais aussi bien sûr des peines
criminelles qui rappelonsle sont pour
certaines d'entre elles prononcé par le
jury
populaire nous n'avons plus de questions
nous vous remercions Monsieur le
Ministre